the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone this is woman's
Grandmaster Sabina foischer and I'm
joined by a national Master Julian
perlacco great to have you here thanks
um let's go ahead and take a look at the
results from last night for the St Louis
Super Source
uh
last night Christopher you and Nicholas
theodoro both on four points made a draw
on board one looks like there were draws
on boards uh on all the top boards one
through five
and the only decisive result was Brian
has gone to uh had an upset against arm
kobian on Board number six
uh and
he had not a lot of decisive results in
in this uh in in the round from last
night that's right a lot of a lot of
draws last night but uh let's CH let's
remind everyone
let's check out the standings uh after
yesterday's round so before the round uh
when we went off uh offline yesterday
with um
Doug we saw Christopher you and Nicolas
theodoro getting you know that pole
position and they they maintained that
pole position their sharing still
sharing first place with four and a half
points uh darush Lazar
brazona Perez Brandon Jacobson harshit
Raja and Brian Escalante are sharing
third and then lots of strong Grand
monsters have three and a half points
and we have a second page for these
standings I believe we don't have we
don't have that's so determined format
is a nine round Swiss tournament with um
the time control being 90 minutes with
30 second increments the roundtimes are
at 11 A.M and uh 5 PM Central Time
and if you guys forgot about it let's
remind you what the schedule for this
tournament was
one more day after today that's kind of
sad and uh Happy maybe for some people
in the same time today Julian and I are
going to do commentary for round seven
we might check out some of the games for
around six just stand by on that but the
round started at 11 A.M the players have
another round round date that starts at
5 p.m that's not going to be broadcasted
here in the studio however you can still
follow the game's life on leeches and
tomorrow will be the last and final
round that will start at 11 A.M and we
will be definitely doing commentary for
that and looking forward to see who the
winners of this event are going to be
don't forget to join us on our social
media follow San Luis chess club and if
you want to
make any tweets you can use the hashtag
STL super Swiss you can check out the
results for this tournament as well as
others on us just champs.com and welcome
everyone who's following our live stream
both on YouTube and twitch
without further ado
I think we should
okay let's let's check out some of the
games that were played yesterday around
six we're still having some technical
difficulties with bringing up around
seven so
um we want to keep you waiting
um so I'll pull up some of the games
from yesterday's round that we didn't
get the chance to look so we talked
about Christopher you uh playing against
Nicolas theodoro
um did you get the chance to look at the
games at all no I haven't checked out
any of the games all right so it's gonna
be brand new commentary until we're
rating on the uh round to get
started okay so let's see so what I feel
that Christopher you was playing for for
a win in this game the game did last for
quite some time they went for a G3 as a
Kings in here we actually have yeah we
have seen this kind of system
in the previous rounds
uh thoughts on this opening journey I
don't have a lot of experience in these
types of positions
um I guess I've played this more with
black than with white but
it's got a solid approach actually for
white you are anticipating you know D6
and suddenly you meet c6d5 and I was
showing the the viewers yesterday that a
lot of people were wondering why isn't
White playing D5 you know because wait
there is there's the opportunity to stop
like from going there but obviously uh
that's not really working because you're
going to lose a pawn with this line
famous trap that you can't uh you can't
fall for because there's Bishop takes E3
everyone's kind of excited about it so
now you know don't go for D5 you should
be mindful about pushing your pawns
forward too soon yeah I would think even
positionally this isn't a good idea just
the pawn on D5 will be exposed later
yeah there's this line in the king's
Indian where they do this or sorry not
in the king's Indian but like this
anti-grunfeld line you know after
um G6 they go D5 to stop black from
going D5 and that isn't considered to be
anything very special
you mean here yeah so instead of Knight
of three or depends on the move or yeah
so if you go C4 G6 people play D5 here
and this isn't considered to be very
good either right because you're pushing
the pawn forward too soon and then you
don't have sufficient pieces to keep it
protected and keep it there in the
center so yeah I mean
their principles for a reason and you
have to kind of follow them in a way
there might be players that are able to
get by without following all the
principles but
um they usually get punished so with you
know you yeah you gotta you gotta be
mindful of specific things
but um looks like I like to call this
the schlechter but yesterday
um Doug was telling me that no no we
just call it the groomfeld I have my way
of calling openings so if you're gonna
hear me say something feel free to let
me know what it is if if it has a
different name because um you know I
just have my own names which can be a
good or bad thing I don't know yeah so
B3 was played D take C4 actually this is
interesting that black thought of
capturing immediately what are your
thoughts about that move would you would
you do that directly it's a little it's
a little weird to me I I always thought
the c65 line was considered to be like
pretty solid and like DC is trying to
imbalance the position which seems
um uh counterproductive to the line that
you're playing but I mean Theodore's
Theodore is obviously a really good
player so I'm sure of course I'm sure he
had yeah I agree he had something
prepared here but
um it seems like he took and he decided
to take advantage of the fact that white
pushed that pawn too soon and now he
played he went for C5 kind of following
the groomfeld ideas of attacking this
Center fast and opening up the bishop
but uh that was really interesting that
yeah he has to play
he actually does not necessarily have to
play C6 he could technically Castle
after Bishop G2 he could play D5 but
maybe in these situations white could
take right yeah so this is the line that
I I thought that people considered to be
like sharper against the G3 system like
most people who want to be solid go c65
try to play the symmetrical position
whereas like people play this to be like
Sharp
so it's interesting that he like mixed
the two ideas yeah yeah
and sometimes it works sometimes you
have to
to take advantage every move your
opponent does something out of the
ordinary and try to see the differences
between something that you're familiar
with and something that you're not and
okay so he's he's attacked the center
fast and now white has remained with a
weakness over there are we by any chance
getting the new rounds are still not
nope still not yet well
I know a lot of people are expecting
around seven but
we don't want to keep you waiting so
we'll we'll go over some of these games
and see some interesting things that
happen so Queen B6
I wonder if this is uh this is a line
that a lot of people play seems like it
is all Theory yeah uh well this is this
is quite interesting I don't know if I
would feel comfortable with white to
play with the spawn structure because
um it could be easy for black to put
pressure but maybe maybe I'm just seeing
ghosts or something because with the
knight in D4 it's difficult to Envision
a bishop going to E6 to put pressure and
then how is this Knight going to to get
to put pressure because if you take it
out in C6 which he did I was about to
say we're gonna take immediately and now
this is not um
upon on a semi-open file anymore so it's
going to be more difficult for black to
put pressure seems pretty balanced to me
this position yeah seems pretty equal so
they they both kind of played it safe in
a way trying to secure their position in
the standings potentially or let's see
so Rook d8
and okay yeah nobody's gonna trade this
is very important to mention nobody
wants to trade because when you trade
you're helping the other side improve
their Pawn structure
and then the pawn that will remain on
the file will remain weak
oh great I every single time I say
something I feel like today is one of
those days where I say something and
it's gonna happen
that does not look very good on me okay
a knight here does it force does it
Force why to take in B6 I don't I don't
know why it would like my first oh yeah
yeah
it does it does force white this idea
with Bishop D4 would not
work so
yes the queen V6 is forced it's
interesting kind of okay this is a good
move so I wonder if
if this was necessary from
from white to play
because this Pawn being weak it does
I wanna I wouldn't want to do that
do you have any other ideas of what we
could do however I can't say one that I
have like a really strong intuition for
this type of position but
yeah I I think the reasoning
behind night uh F3 is just like
if if you do Force this trade like ab6
maybe eventually I'll play Bishop G7 kg7
and Knight D4 and C6 will be weak
that seems to have happened after the
trade in Basics 94 was played I mean I
really don't like the pawn structure but
if you somehow manage to get some
initiative here in a way or maybe get
the bishop pair which he kind of did
yeah actually I'm curious why he didn't
play Bishop takes G7 first instead of
knight uh Knight Knight D4 I guess
Knight C3 is like a big problem is that
true
window like Knight D4 Knight C3 is what
he was afraid of maybe
two
well
it like takes and then rookie one Rook
D2 probably black is happy with that
okay to take yeah
rookie one and then Rook D2 probably
black is happy about this right yeah
yeah yeah this seems a little bit
unpleasant and you don't you kind of
have to make that decision
um you cannot just play three because
your Rook is hanging and you can't just
make this mode of course because it's a
small tactic here so that seems forcing
totally forcing
so I guess you didn't want to allow
black to get any activity Knight D4 just
stops that but you do remain pinned but
now black cannot just move the bishop
because the Knight is hanging and you
don't have Knight C3 for one more moment
and I like that he captured in B2 here
so the game just I think both players
just played um then the best moves and
the position was just balanced when they
agreed on a draw
if we take here instead
how do I continue
probably Bishop G7 is forced
and now we still have this nice E3 idea
so owners Rook D3 I think I wonder like
how forcing we can be like can we play
Bishop takes E4 Rook takes d8 and Rook
B1
does that lead to anything for us
and now what did you say Rook takes Rook
takes d8 and then Rook B1
this end game
this is interesting I'm not totally sure
I like I would say I I
would say I like black here
so maybe go King F1 first
if I were you I wouldn't give that pawn
up
because if you take him B6
you want to take E2 I guess I was going
to although you might be able to have
this in between move but I don't think
it helps too much because I have yeah
and you don't want to put your rook in
in A4 that would be very unpleasant
yeah I mean I'm not sure who's playing
for what in this 4v4 end game like after
Rook takes C6
it is kind of strange it's kind of a
strange setup because in a way you feel
that black has more pawns and he does
have more pawns on the king side but in
the same time he's missing the G Pawn so
it might not be so easy for them to
um
so okay so say this position would arise
what is the evaluation of this
probably it's like everywhere in game
it's a draw it just it could be just a
draw it could be just a draw I mean it's
nice to have the the past Pawn further
but
it is definitely very tricky
I guess I guess the players didn't
really want to
um
get into those kind of complications
here
um yeah the okay they got into an
opposite color Bishop with Rooks on the
board but this is this is quite simple
and they agreed on a draw a move later
seems like a pretty well played game by
both sides yeah I agree I agree
I
were both trying to play for a win
actually when you see the game although
I know it did end up
um
seeing in the end that a lot of pieces
got traded off and they went for a draw
I think still those quotes on play and
there were a lot of calculations that
required sorry a lot of variations that
required calculation because
um
there are lots of trains that were
possible so you had to kind of evaluate
what types of end games you wanted to go
into and yeah okay
um some of the games didn't have don't
have the result yet but I think this
game would remember it did end in a draw
between Raja harshit and darshwirtz were
still waiting on around seven to
um
to be uploaded actually let's go for a
win let's show everyone a witness we're
waiting I know there are a couple of
games that were quite interesting
actually
um there was an upset right between
Brian Escalante I mean Kobe and Brian
Escalante yeah let's let's see how this
game was played because
this broad brand Escalante
into the shared third place after he won
this game against Aram hogabian if I
remember correctly the sendings and
it was
finally a king's Indian kind of but not
quite because white hasn't played C4 yet
so I can still change their mind whether
they want to play C4 or not so but black
has committed with D6 compared to what
I've seen in the previous game in these
positions depending on how
you choose your move order black and
also go D5 and kind of transpose to the
previous line that we've seen
some kind of gronfeld but once you
commit to D6 you're probably going to go
for the king's Indian I mean that's
that's yeah but C4 although you know the
main thing I actually have seen a lot of
people going for B3 Bishop B2 first or
sometimes their ideas even with B4 it's
a little bit crazy maybe not
specifically right now you should you
should be mindful when you push that
pawn because you can't allow A5 if you
push too soon but which choice is very
strange so uh what is what is working on
I think you she probably wanted to
transpose to some pierc to E4 and just
get E4 in now that you've committed to
playing D6 not D5 you know white wants
to just say I'm going to transpose to E4
and black is like you know what I've
changed my mind I don't think how your
rookie new one is going to be helpful in
these positions so there D5 no more no
more e4s
um let's play the position down in Tempo
but arguably rookie one isn't like a
very important move right and in some
situation
but
not going anywhere anytime soon and you
typically want to put your Rooks on open
files or those that you're sure can get
opened and here doesn't and F2 will be
weak so he transposed to well he could
have transposed to the previous game
we've seen but hakopion might have been
thinking about winning this game so he
went for cc C3
this is quite interesting
um this is quite an interesting setup
because
it's kind of a color but not really a
color system because you've developed a
bishop in G2 instead of D3 and the
King's Indian setup so yeah so when I
say C3 I'm thinking he wants to play
against the bishop on G7 but I'm curious
what his intention is against C5 like
does he want to take the pawn because
yes he probably does so he's gonna play
Reverse
maybe reversed Catalan or reversed
yeah it's like a reverse symmetrical
grunefeld of some sort yeah but it's
like the Rooks on E1 so it can help
sometimes because the black does playing
A5 in some of the groomfield ideas I
think so it depends
um
let's see how the game went so A5 was
played first interesting
Bishop F4 now C5 what is A5 all about
I've seen people trying to get a little
bit more space on the queen side and
either playing against potentially maybe
B3 and so he's trying to kind of mess up
this chain of Pawns since as you said
white is going to play against this
bishop I've seen people do that a lot
but
yeah I see good players play this A5 all
the time and I just you know I just
don't get it
so inside
in sangha's
you don't mess up too badly the B5
square if this does not become a great
Outpost for white in a way I think
this move will be helpful at some point
in an end game it turns out being
helpful I've seen it being played in The
Stonewall as well when black gets this
kind of set up with
you know c6c65 of course and then
sometimes they do that to get a little
bit more space and get their their
Bishop r36 so they want that pawn push
to make sure that in some situations
that you can actually trade the bishop
but okay here that's not the case so
let's see how that move was helpful I
think you can only find out at the end
you know in the beginning you're just
like what
what has been going on and then in the
end it just helped
all right it seems like we have round
seven so maybe we can just finish this
game fast see how he won and then we'll
get you guys back to round seven which
is gonna be very exciting because we're
approaching the end
oh look at that so he
he did get this okay but this position
is
who's better here
I don't know anymore and there's an
extra pump for white but
um but black is the bishop pair and
um okay he's got his palm back this Pawn
is hanging this Pawn is hanging as well
okay so they trade it off and it's not
too bad it is not too bad so there must
have been a moment in this game where
blundered probably or else how would he
lose
this rock looks them to be trapped
you reckon C4 doesn't look too hot right
now
yeah he's not I don't know if his pieces
are really very well coordinated so
black Force the trade and now black
spaces are definitely better placed you
know it just looks like black has the
two Bishops for not a lot of
compensation yeah a small advantage and
probably he was able to just to somehow
outplay his opponent there must oh two
Bishop just one okay just one upon and
now wait wait we're getting it back
we're getting it back
takes still equal but there's Rook C1
Rook A1 and that pawn is lost so at the
end of the calculation you just end up a
pawn down and I guess you want this end
game which is impressive
extra Pawn listen that's that's that's
uh that's all you need sometimes to be
able to to win but guys if you want to
check out uh the games
they're all only chess and now we got
around seven so I suggest we just go
into that
um for just one moment I'm going to have
to change the scene so hopefully it's
not going to mess up anything maybe we
can pull in the standings once again as
I'm changing the scene so that
parents let's let's appearance for
around seven get you guys up to speed
with that
so on board one is Lazaro brazon against
Christopher you uh Four Points versus
four and a half points definitely a game
that will affect uh the tournament in a
major way Nicholas theodoro uh versus
Brendan Jacobson I have a feeling that
both of these players are looking for
blood theodoru and Jacobson both very
very fighting players so
um and predict a result on this board
Daria Schwartz against Yasser uh uh
yesterday Perez I believe
and um
uh and Brian Escalante which we just saw
a game of versus Raja harshit it seemed
like the uh the games of the leaders
that we'll probably be checking out yeah
we'll mostly be uh looking at those
games and
I think we can get started unless we
have do we have a second page
all right who is the second page for
around seven so you guys can see all of
the players we have
uh lost a few players along the way but
that's okay that's okay it's a very
tough tournament and I think
um you know lots of lessons can be
learned regardless of how you do in any
tournament
um and there's always you know a strong
one coming after don't worry don't worry
Julian so let's I I started talking
about it and then I realized that you
you did not do it very well so I just
want you to know that I am I am I
believe in you and I believe in you and
I know you're going to come back so just
don't give up okay that's that's my
quote that I always like to tell
everyone so I'll try my best all right
all right good okay so let's get into
into the first board as you said these
first two uh games we're definitely
going to spend a lot of time on right
yeah
against Christopher you and Theodore
Nicholas against Brandon Jacobson I
suggest we started with the first game
yeah
um they already made quite a number of
moves and
so we missed we missed a lot of the
opening Catalan as bruzon's Choice
Bishop B4 check okay Christopher has
played these kind of things before and I
think he's usually very good with his
opening preparation yeah I think it's
worth pointing out why to move forward
decision so like when when you play G3
Bishop G2 in this order because I play
the Catalan with both colors
um instead of starting with Knight F3
Bishop G2 is actually aimed at this
bishop before checkline because after
Bishop G2 Bishop B4 you have the ability
here to play the move on Knight D2
uh and normally this would not be super
critical because of D takes C4 but in
this position Queen A4 check wins a
piece oh
my idea of showing uh trap solution
what's what's surprising is that
actually there was a game
that's crazy probably that was user
error if I had to guess maybe maybe but
okay black gets two pawns for the piece
but it's definitely uh an important not
super impressive
this is this is a very cool idea thanks
for sharing that
um hopefully the audience has enjoyed it
too yeah so if you can of course play in
this position Knight F3 but then the
same thing doesn't happen oops sorry 92
because now um DC is is possible for you
96 is perfectly fine black protects the
pawn okay the game goes on of course
it's not
there's nothing uh bad about it you can
still play this but of course trying to
set up a trap for the opponent is always
nice I've been reading this book
um I think it's called the swindlers uh
chess or something like that by
Grandmaster
um
and he he talks about those kind of
setups but it's usually in worse
positions but you know you can do it for
better positions you can do it yeah yeah
why not why not you know you got to set
up some traps but set it out set them up
in like a more like a normal way don't
make it too obvious because if you make
it too obvious then you know
it's gonna be an issue
because your reporter will see it and
then uh yeah so Knight F3 Castle Queen
C2 was played C5 all right so
black in a way kind of restricts their
Bishop here and before but they still
have the option to trade it so until
White Castles you're not worried that
white is going to move the bishop and
then have a three
but with the C5 you're weakening B5
Square I'm not the most familiar with
this specific positions because I
usually try to play with Knight to D2
this is interesting that he's chosen to
have the bishop there instead but
they're still Theory Queen B6
E3 yeah both of these players won over
2600 the other not much below 2600
obviously very well prepared in there in
their opening opening preparation yeah
Ponte so
after Castle 96 I'm trying to catch up
with the game since we've missed quite a
lot of it at this point unfortunately
but that's okay Knight takes C6 are we
forced to make this move I would not
really want to make the move just yet
but
um usually I enjoy to play against an
isolated Pawn
but I think in this position we might
have to make the trade Bishop C3
probably does not bring much
too white
there's an interesting move I guess the
point is you want to play bc3
yeah I do but now I've created a
weakness for myself too so and I don't
have the dark secret Bishop to go Bishop
A3 anymore I probably have to
um I'd probably have to develop this
Knight here and bring it to play
maybe I'll go see four rupee one
I would feel a little bit more
comfortable playing this position with
white
um yeah me too I would prefer to be
white here over black
but he chose to take n66 which allows
black to capture back with the pawn so
now we're dealing with
hanging Pawns
but they are they might not be so strong
and this is uh this is what brazon could
be playing against and trying to put a
lot of pressure on the C Pawn Rook C1 he
goes for it immediately
and Christopher does not want to protect
so he goes Rook B8 with the point that
if you capture which did not happen but
if you do capture
I think we'll take
hopefully I'm right takes takes takes
Rook takes
and who's better in this position
hmm
at this point like black has a weak a
weak Pawn on D5 but he has an active
Rook on B2
I don't know
I don't even yeah I don't know who I'd
prefer playing maybe black honestly
the pawn on like even if you lose the
pawn on D5 for the bishop on G2 then
there's Bishop E6 and trying to go for
this maybe should be okay for black
yeah I think this this would be fine and
it's trading a little bit too many
pieces maybe brazon is trying to keep a
little bit more on the board and trying
to when you're playing with the white
pieces typically you're trying to keep
more the pressure whether
um you're the stronger player or not I
think typically they try to to keep more
pressure on the board
and more pieces
so now you don't have the opportunity to
take it of course you just give up the
bishop pair for no reason
so black Richard Queen d8 this is an
interesting move here what do you think
about this move
well probably this moon is aimed
directly against Knight A4 I think in
the previous position Knight A4 was was
White's idea yes of course Knight A4
um aiming at the C5 square and the C6
Pawn of course
[Music]
um and then B3 after after the Bishops
would eventually get traded we might
play B3 not to hang our pawn and B2 and
then yes definitely we want to bring the
Knight to the to the C5 square but
obviously
that is still an option isn't it yeah he
did not play it but
it's still an idea for a way to bring
the Knight to C5
but but usually you know what they say
when a knight goes away from the control
of the center another one could come
towards the center which
I don't think it works just yet
94 is an interesting interesting move I
guess it does sacrifice some material
it does uh in the previous position yeah
you you put Knight A4 you were saying
Knight E4 no no I was saying that's at
some point for black not yet not yet but
even
even be interesting right because you
can't take on e4 twice in the current
position because d2's hanging yeah no I
was thinking take stakes and then takes
and then you will stay with a lot of
weaknesses now yeah it takes before
um technically Queen takes C6 I think
you have Bishop D7 so that's not gonna
be a great idea maybe B3 first
yeah but you have to be like super care
like here you could imagine like Bishop
G4 to F3 and who who has the initiative
yeah this Knight is
not doing now it's not really ideally
placed there I totally agree and there's
no Rook D1 either which would be another
idea I would have so yeah we do take
this Pawn
but maybe our King safety is going to be
yeah like maybe you just have long-term
compensation here
it could be it could be and Christopher
had a really brilliant win the previous
round against
that was in round five yesterday morning
and he had
um this oh yeah his Bishop was on F3 in
that game too I think it was innate I
believe it was an H3 because it was oh
no no yeah I was restricting there was a
king in G1 and rook in H1 those totally
restricted too right yeah yeah and then
eventually that led to a rook end game
that he was he was able to convert
without much trouble it was it was
definitely a very strong positional
advantage that he had with some
attacking ideas so I really love that
game I thought he played really really
good although at first I thought his
position had
or his preparation might have had some
problems but he turned the game in his
favor quite nicely so if you guys didn't
see that game I highly recommend
checking it out it was Chris
um tip off against Christopher you from
around
five
um okay so this is probably an
interesting idea I didn't realize it
would be I thought I was just saying
some nice idea sometimes I just say it
before I can think you through what
about this
and not giving up our Bishop just yet
just taking I believe you have surgery
or something we can't take just yet
because of this
oh wait okay wait we can right yeah
Queen takes default because there's
Bishop Bishop Bishop E4
and
I think I think what is good do we trade
or do we not trade I don't know well
let's trade
Yeah lyrics
okay so uh who is better here we don't
know it lights up a pawn so yeah sure
better black doesn't have sufficient
compensation in this case he does not
have okay fine fine so maybe that pawn
is able to be captured do you have other
moves in this position with black to try
to
keep the position
okay so I did play Bishop here and you
took wait wait wait wait we have an
in-between move that I forgot this is
what happens when you go on the line and
you don't go back uh yeah
yeah and inconvenient and then I take so
that's okay okay so all right okay we
cannot take the pawn or yeah we cannot
so B3
but I definitely don't want to give out
my Bishop from G2 that would be very
very unpleasant I'd say
so B3 and now
um now C6 is hanging for real yeah so
probably he should deal with that in
some way
maybe bishop D7
but this is uh he chose something else
in the game right yes he did he did I
just thought I just thought this was
interesting to try to get the Knight
there because it's it's quite a typical
idea but I guess he played 92 with a
similar idea so he's trying to attract
maybe this Pawn to go to C5 so he might
want to play Knight to D4
and um
in a track that move eventually
obviously in the night here also has
threats with Knight C6 that's gonna Fork
black so black kind of had to trade
trade and now Queen B6
B3 very natural I mean
I would do that too yeah maybe I mean
it's kind of it seems very normal but
now you'll see this move eventually
there will be A4 because you're
wondering what's going to happen you
never see it in the beginning like
um I think
okay so Bishop G4 and now he went back
to C3 see that's why I'm surprised about
very interesting he's gonna go back to
A4 I'm telling you because that's an
idea and yeah he just wanted probably to
trade the Bishops but there must have
been something after Knight A4 that he
didn't like
and now he's going back I wonder if this
was an option but
probably I wasn't going to do that much
maybe we can yeah
it's always so tricky that question yeah
I don't know C5 Rook d8
something where does the night go
actually
you still have to go back to E2
because
you want to usually put pressure on
those pawns so now suddenly if you could
play this move of course you would be
happy but
that move is not allowed legally allowed
at the moment so you can bring the
Knight back towards A4 put some more
pressure
but he chose Knight C3 so he's going for
this idea and Christopher played Queen
before to pin the Knight and restrict
demo from happening obviously now
because the queen is protected you don't
have a move like Knight E4
so you have to come up with a way to
what about coin Beach oh okay so here's
the thing Queen B2 looks nice right
everything looks good you escape the pin
and everything
but A4 and wait wait wait I again spoke
too soon
I was going to show this gorgeous idea
and then I saw this
yeah who is better now well I was so
excited about my queen B2 it's actually
the very typical actually this this
these kinds of moves you play them in
the Ninja quite often with with white
when you get rid of that bishop or
sometimes the bishop plus 2 C3 and you
have these ideas
and you have more space so there could
be like a very funny line where like I
don't know black plays like rookie eight
or something and then you're like Knight
A4 I'm really smart because Queen A4
Queen F6 and then black plays Queen A2
and then white plays uh Queen G7 or
something yeah and then we get this
position and then probably white is for
Choice yeah white should be oh it should
be better yeah I think if you take I
take here well you can't take seats yeah
because B1 check yeah but you can take
A5 and
well but then you do get some activity
here
look here
uh maybe maybe we start with H3 maybe
that's smart because after uh
you have to go to D7 right and then we
can go Rook A7
and try to try to play with our own
activity
although probably just equal the more I
think about it
or maybe not equal but probably black
should hold
I mean
yeah black has a slider or spawn
structure but if you don't get to attack
it I don't think it's much worse
you could probably go
I wanted to say rookie seven and then
somehow protect the rook and then try to
offer a trade because the stroke is
quite active I'm curious if why so this
is some real nonsense but I wonder if
you can take on D5 here oh on D5 I
thought maybe you're on D7 and then C6
you know it takes Rook C7
I wonder if I'm missing some major
tactic probably am yeah and then like
Teenage two
um
so I mean okay we'll get into this end
game but should be I think it should be
a draw if anything Black's playing
yeah well now we have this move so no
it's going to be a joke yeah I was
thinking you would go to D2 with your
Rook if you wanted to try to play but
it's okay for a win that's like 56 and
you can't I mean I have the C4 so you
think no but that I was thinking brick
D6 and just hold it
sure this should be this should be a
draw yeah we're really far we're really
far from the from the game but that's an
interesting this idea with Knight F4 is
interesting you just need to make sure
you calculate that there's no
extra escape with the queen either for
white or for black after the queen
captures
yeah I try not to play moves like Knight
A4 because the likelihood that I'm wrong
is like it isn't very low and the upside
is so tiny right like the upside is
maybe I get some slightly better end
game and the downside is I blundered my
knight for nothing
but this position is a little bit crazy
because we could have taken F7 instead
of G7 like I did
and um
or maybe we could just move the queen
somewhere no we can just well wait could
I just move the queen somewhere no
because there's Queenie too
I mean the thing is we see a line and we
really get very excited when we do
commentary so you want to show it to the
audience but obviously uh calculation
doesn't happen over five seconds right
so we try to show you the first thing
that we see but of course sometimes we
can miss things because
there's not sufficient time to evaluate
everything so we realized that we're
going over this line and it looks great
and then at the end
um you have to when you're actually
making your own calculations you have to
go back a few moves to make sure
everything was forcing and you haven't
missed stuff on the way like here we
both have our Queens hanging but
if I move the queen somewhere to keep
your Bishop under attack
your queen is still under attack and I
attacked the bishop so where do you move
it to E2 is
and I have the feeling that if I attack
this queen now
um well
yeah you attack the queen probably black
goes like H6 but it's like black has
done a lot of nonsense
to try it it's not game over yeah I I
don't I don't give up on this yet
someone in the chat is joking that we
are human yes surprisingly we're human
we might we might be aliens but you know
you'll never know
we'll never tell
Quinn Quinn too okay so yeah no no no
it should be pretty convincing the
black's lost okay okay so maybe maybe in
that position after Queen before maybe
this is an option then
because if we take takes and we can
actually take wait but that was this
other line where they could take but
what is the evaluation here
well this is better than the other line
I think because we have an extra Pawn we
do we do and then that's hanging as well
we still kept our Bishop which is very
important not to get mated or stay on a
back rank mate issues
and then
yeah we might be able to survive in this
position somehow
yeah if black plays something like
Bishop D7 here maybe we can play E4
and then after if you play D4 here then
I'll play Rook C4 so you're keeping that
attack that's
that protected this attack you can bring
in the other Rook too you might give up
the E2 Pawn but then your your rookies
is coming into play
do you want to take a look at the uh the
Theodore uh Jacob sorry of course we
caught up with the game I was I was a
fast to catch up because
so much
of a name yeah some dgters I know I know
we apologize about that but hopefully
you guys got still
something going
this Caleb in the chat
uh Caleb is in the chat and he says that
he would never admit to being an onion
which which is a smart move on his part
yeah
support that decision
hi Calum you're welcome to join us
anytime if you want
maybe just put him on the chat on the on
the spot he'll be like it really is
having a fine tomorrow you're out
um Bishop B5 okay so we had a relo pass
or not yes Ray Lopez Bishop there
um the rookie one okay so this is this
is quick theory yes uh there are some
other move there are 10 000 ideas here
um
that and not ten thousand but you can
you can take the pawn as well of course
if you want to yeah you can play the
open Roy you can play The Arc angles you
can play the classical yeah so many
things you can
you come C5 we
have food has a name I don't know
the arcangles I think yeah this is the
one yeah okay I I mean maybe it's that
and then Bishop to B7 I can't I can't
remember it's something that Bishop B7 I
just
yeah
um
but yeah this this opening is a lot more
okay I'm gonna I I've always felt this
opening is a lot more about ideas than
actual like memorization but there's
obviously like a lot of theory in this
type of positions there is you can
certainly yeah and there are various
setups that black and choose to play uh
oh white went for A4 okay
this is an anti-martial setup yes yes
with D5 which I think you get the
Marshall if black plays D3 here right uh
no so the Marshall is is rookie one like
what he did and then B5 Bishop B3
castles and then if you play C3 here ah
here
yeah so this this is how you get it yeah
black argues that the pawn on C3 means
that Knight C3 is not possible so he can
play for compensation here with C6 and
some attack on the king side and if you
want to play this probably you know you
should check out some of the games by
Iranian he's played a lot of
these Marshals
yeah and definitely spend a lot of time
on the computer analyzing with the
computer before you go on and play this
they're tactical ideas but you also have
to to know what was previously played if
you want to play it yeah so A4 is aimed
directly at D5 so obviously D5 is
impossible in this position because B5
is hanging so black needs to respond in
some way
so there's some typical
three typical moves I've played rupee
eight a couple of times myself here
um B4 sometimes I think
um
can be scary because you've pushed the
spawn a little bit too much but it does
play against this idea with an ic3 so
white usually plays D3 and maybe later
we'll get to play C3 yeah but root B8 is
the move that was chosen by Brandon
Jacobson in this game yeah the big
downside of B4 is that you give the C4
Square to White so like white wants to
play Knight D2 Knight C4 and that could
be pretty annoying that's another idea
yes and I've played some I was saying C3
because I've gotten that played against
me as well and after capture sometimes
I think it was no it's absolutely
there's some ideas when this Knight can
come to D5 I forgot exactly if it's in
this line or if even in the Rook V8 line
because Knight C3 is possible and the
game it doesn't seem that it happened
that way but this idea with the Knight
coming to D5 can get dangers because you
know once you take Bishop takes and then
you have to get rid of the Bishop from
here and it's not so easy five is really
well secured yeah
was Brendan Jacob's son's idea in this
position captures C3 so now he's
he's preparing
um third door is preparing to go for D4
yeah so I guess D4 right away he was
afraid of some Bishop G4 idea but
probably not in the email position you
mean in this position yeah so it's like
D4
um you can't play Bishop G4 now because
D5 wins a piece right yeah they usually
capture and then they go Bishop G4 and
black I think gets D5 as well
I think this is the line and then at
some point you get this yeah so that's
all I remember I see I see the line
that's said in the database line which
is Bishop E3 and it's it's it's cool to
point out that Bishop E3 here is
possible because after Knight E4 Bishop
D5 would win a piece so this is like a
typical idea in these variations
definitely you can lose a piece like
that in other lines in Larry Lopez
possibly in the Italian as well so just
keep in mind and don't take the pawn
unless you're sure this move is not
possible I remember losing a game like
this when I was 1700 I was very upset my
opponent played Bishop D5 I was doubt a
piece
I remember I prepared one time the first
time I I started playing E5 again a few
years back I played as a kid but then
you know I didn't play for some time and
then every single time I would play B5 I
would be very scared of any move Bishop
D5 because I thought that was an option
for white it never works and not just
capturing the pawn just in general this
move of Penny my knight and I thought
I'm losing a piece if I played D6 and I
always would spend 10-15 minutes in the
opening to make sure that move is not
possible so I was waste time for no
reason because that move wasn't even
good but I thought it was so it's very
important to know as many ideas as
possible when you're gonna study some
kind of opening whatever it may be it's
much better to spend 10 minutes for no
reason and making sure that you don't
lose a piece then to not spend any time
and just blender a piece though so
that's debatable I don't know yeah I
don't know because because those 10
minutes could be very much helpful
towards you know the end of the game
when you don't have time it's an end
game and you have to calculate things
and you don't have the time so I mean
obviously you don't want a blunder but
okay so let's see so B4 was played here
interesting I guess that's the main one
I would play Bishop B7 myself if I were
to play here with black but
Brandon went for B4 let's see
D3
so now that this Pawn is challenged you
don't want to go for D4 I guess because
they would take and now you'd have to go
maybe there's a tactic here like if you
take on C3 as night or some 94 at some
point possible no there's still Bishop
D5
so what is
huh not nice before what was your idea
I was hallucinating never mind
it's the room okay it's on the room
I don't or the lights the lights we got
too many lights
yeah
okay so I don't know about this uh this
D4
in this position why it does not work
but Nicholas wants to be more cautious I
guess keeping his positions safe first
maybe he still wants to go for this idea
I'm very curious why D4 isn't isn't
played because we can put the we can put
the engine for a second to check yeah
it's not even one of the main it's not
in the top five moves
but it's also a good move yeah every
move is good for white yeah okay white
has a better position so we found the
right of
right okay make sure you give us credit
whatever this is it's impossible to make
a mistake yeah top six moves all lead to
an advantage for what yeah unless you're
just going to play Bishop takes F7 and
sacrifice you know pieces otherwise this
is the this is the move that wins
um no but like uh seriously what's wrong
with this
I mean this is this is quite typical of
course and D5 sure
White's better after every legal move
for a really long period of time in the
opening but
we need to give the computer some
thought eventually it will be zero zero
probably E5 would be something you want
to play and then you allow night here
and then you have to find the right
development for these pieces
but okay let's see how the game went
since we know this is perfectly fine oh
wait D3 is one move that does not give
so much advantage to right it gives up
some of the advantage so maybe you
should have gone for D4
okay
but we're joking a little bit but I mean
I I do not
um
I don't know how Theodore is actually
approaching this position
because this is round seven he's on four
and a half sharing first place with
Christopher you uh he's got the white
pieces so in a way maybe he should
pressure a little bit you should put a
little bit of pressure on his opponent
because he has the white pieces but at
the same time he doesn't want to over
pressure not to lose and lose his first
a shared place so it is always tricky
psychology is very important as I always
talk about this
um because you cannot just
um play the game sometimes you have to
play the opponent sometimes you have to
play the you have to keep a lot of
ideas yeah so open Theodore since he's
white they're um
there should be two rounds after this
right yeah so this game and in the
following two games will have two out of
two out of three uh games with white and
Christopher you will have two out of
three games with black should be
most likely but you never know there
could be some doubling but probably not
so I guess
um from that perspective theodoro has
like an advantage in the tournament
maybe a slight one at least I would be
happier with theodoro and I would
definitely want to put a lot of pressure
with the white pieces
okay make Christopher you prove
something in a way yeah uh yeah that's
that's true but also
I often realize that when you're
focusing too much on your opponent what
your opponent is doing or
then you're losing focus from your own
game so he shouldn't look that much of
what Christopher does but more focused
on his games and try to play get the
best games that he can and of course
they're it's not like they're the first
two that they cannot be caught in the
standings because there are a lot of
players with four points that could win
and and catch up so yeah there are
definitely a lot of sharks uh with four
points yeah so keeping the position
I mean I see this list with four points
and they're all like 2 600 Grand Masters
I know I know it's a very strong
tournament if you guys
you know are just joining us now
this is hopefully this tournament will
be organized in the future we'll
continue check out the standings that we
have our team has put on the screen for
you so once again Christopher you and
Nicolas their daughter are sharing first
place with four and a half and look at
all these monsters with four points six
players right six players with four
points sharing third and then look at
all these Grand monsters or three and a
half too Ilya niznik had 26.99 feet at
some point three and a half points
yeah rough tournament
it's a very tough tournament I mean it's
probably one of the toughest
um out there with with so many strong
players battling for we actually haven't
reminded you of this but I wonder if
our team can pull up the price funds so
that we can remind you
what the players are playing for
yeah they're playing for six thousand
dollars first place prize
um right behind that four thousand for
second three thousand four third and uh
2004 uh fourth place
and so on but there's definitely a lot
of money total of 25 uh 25 000 in the
prize fund yeah a few
I think we are close to the finish of it
so it's going to be an exciting finish
let's catch up with this game before
we'll have to go
on a short or longer break
um so okay so uh Brendan went for D
takes E4 here which makes sense
and now D takes E4 so the position is
still symmetrical
um
development wise is about the same I
think we lost and there was there's this
game that was played um between nepo and
Magnus as well a few years back yeah
probably both players know about this
game right like I have the feeling they
may oh but no Brendan went for H6
instead of Bishop D6 in this position
that's what Magnus had played but H6
okay maybe
uh maybe it's worth turning the engine
like right right now just to see if H6
is some improvement over Bishop D6
because
yeah so H6 is the top engine move so
probably this is a computer inspired
novelty
that I'm sure Brendan has a lot of
knowledge with
because I know he he's spending a lot of
time analyzing
various openings yeah Brandon's a very
serious player he is he's I've seen him
in a few tournaments and
um
always seem knowledgeable of what he
does he actually was interviewed in a
a few rounds Ago by Jacob and he went
over his win against Costa and it was
really nice to listen to his thinking
process as he was dominating that game
I believe it was round three if I'm not
mistaken
so okay so Queen C2 Bishop D6 Knight F1
okay so these are very typical moves
that both players have done very typical
to bring the Knight here the 1964
probably he thought wasn't going to do
enough so he's bringing the pieces for
potential kingside attack but
Queen's theater is a very he wants
probably this I don't think he wants to
sacrifice actually I should turn off the
engine yeah
appreciate Bishop E6 is one of those
things that I always get wrong like I
play it in positions and then my
opponent takes the bishop and plays
Knight of five and crushes me okay and
then when I don't do it my opponent has
this really strong light squared Bishop
that also like you know
it is annoying and sometimes if a queen
gets to to come somewhere here in G3 G4
and then suddenly gets Queen G6 out of
nowhere right that's definitely an issue
so
um but let's catch up with the game so
Bishop E3 Bishop E60 did not capture I
wonder if black was considering Pawn
takes yeah
maybe Pawn takes so let's see
let's see so this is the current
position let's get you guys up to Speed
Queen to D3 and
um
I have a feeling this game is going for
a draw as well
The Bishop's going to be traded there
are some ideas with queen G3 but I doubt
that white will be able to break through
in this position black does not have any
weaknesses this this is a little bit
weak but
are your thoughts
I think yeah probably I agree with all
with all that the only thing I would be
concerned with a little bit I think I'd
rather be white like just a little bit
because it's the Knight on F5 is pretty
good and like Queen D5 could come at An
Inconvenient time and disrupt like
Black's position but overall probably
the position is pretty low if I had to
guess
[Music]
well guys uh we were told
we have to
we have an extended break uh we'll be
back around 1 50 p.m central time or
hopefully sooner than that hopefully you
stay with us or come back around that
time thank you so much and hopefully see
you soon have a good one
thanks
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hi everyone we are back apologizes about
the longer break I am joined by a
special guest hi Caleb hello I won't be
here long I'm just coming to say Hi how
are you doing
I'm doing great my tournament's going
great because I dropped out so I don't
have to play anymore okay so now you're
just feeling excited about doing some
commentary until yes I wanted to pop in
say hi it's my birthday oh 24. thank you
all right
um all lots of presents from from the
chess club uh walked in no cake nobody
knew but that's fine I'm not mad yeah I
just found out right that was so thanks
for not saying that that's great I'm
gonna write it down for next time fair
enough okay my tournament went okay I
went one and a half out of five played
some good games played some bad games
but I decided to take some time off for
my birthday and just just relax
um I just show up back tomorrow for the
last round or no no chess chess is pain
so we're we're taking a break well you
know how it goes sometimes you have good
tournaments sometimes bad ones and you
just yeah I mean this tournament
honestly I I got my first real win of
2023 so I'm I'm flying high even though
I lost a few games too okay that's um
but what's going on in this tournament I
don't even know Sabina who's winning
it's been a crazy tournament so we have
two players in the lead Christopher you
and uh Nicolas de odoro they played
against each other yesterday and they
drew and we were watching before going
on break with uh with Julian we're
watching some of their positions and see
what was happening
um in the break I just kind of try to
take a look yes I still seem pretty
balanced but I'm sure you guys talked
about it on the show I saw just some
ridiculous looking game with theodoru
and and sweets uh in one of the evening
rounds and just uh there's some crazy
like stalemate trick and then Theodore
just immediately found phone Checkmate
yeah yeah that was that was definitely
one of the best position on games that
I've seen yeah is one of my kind of
games that I liked yesterday Christopher
you also when he started he had a great
game against uh mihail antipov in the
morning he had a positional game where
his opponent's Rook was stuck in H1 and
there was a king in G1 a bishop and H3
kind of keeping those two pieces
restricted in the end it turned out to
be a rook end game that he converted
into a win but lots of positional games
um so so it's really it's really um it's
really an exciting tournament and I
can't wait to see the final game
tomorrow yeah looking forward to it
um it's much more fun to spectate than
to play so I'll I'll have to tune into
the show tomorrow yeah we've seen you
into the show earlier this morning you
were you're checking out yeah I popped
in uh popped in to see see the games but
how is Christopher do feeling this one
looks like he's uh it seems quite
balanced I think this position I mean I
guess white is gonna try to play for for
a win if he's he's bringing in the king
um black is is going to try to play for
the defense here because the pawn is
very weak
um yeah it looks like brazon was able to
kind of come put some pressure on on
Christopher it looks like Black's
definitely trying to hold I think um
it's not gonna be easy
so I'm a little curious why white didn't
play King G3 last turn I'm wondering if
there was F4 I guess I think so yeah F4
takes and then white would take and
black would take so obviously I guess
what black is trying to do is simplify
the position and so if black can play F4
then that's a huge deal because you
could get pawns off the board you free
up your position a little bit he could
technically play a four and well no
obviously Bishop C4 is this way yeah
yeah yeah yeah but um
makes a lot of sense to me you want to
stop that King from getting in but maybe
I guess yeah it feels like like black is
kind of getting out like Rick F6 doesn't
lead to anywhere yeah Bishop on D7 is is
a pretty good Defender actually
but I have a feeling that white is still
having some ideas and trying to put
pressure on me I think he sleeps first I
think you kind of have to stop Rook G4
though Rook G4 is is a threat
how much do I care about that I wonder
if I could just play Rook F6 probably
not yeah my idea is that uh I was
thinking maybe I can give up the pawn I
could be I could be wrong I could be
totally wrong too scary for me I didn't
know you guys allowed tactics on the
show we tried we tried to get get into
some messy positions because they are
not our pieces so we can afford to to
sacrifice a little bit I'm not sure if
this line Works looks like you just you
have just I think squares
Yeah well yeah and obviously if if you
just defend the pawn with King H3 then
um I don't know I think I'm good I think
I'm getting a piece now oh
too scary you go there it's over so
definitely some pressure then so you
cannot really do that it looks like
there was a move actually in this space
so not Rick G7 but now it seems like the
door might be open for King G3
is coming to G4
I I honestly even wanted to play F4
first and that way the king can't come
in but it is scary even this position is
scary so it's instead of Rook G7 if you
start with F4
oh and then you can go Rook G7 to G4
okay right right right that works and
now you're getting the part you still
can go to G4 you need to eat different
pieces of text but now you can go to H6
H6 are here maybe H6
to keep your Rook from getting okay you
can put your Bishop in F5 though yeah
this looks like one of those positions
where maybe black hat should give up a
pawn just to make the task a little
easier actually but yeah definitely
because when you give up the pawn these
pawns are doubled so it seems like it
would be easier to hold yeah a nice idea
to mention for black as a defensive
mechanism is if you manage to trade
those four pawns here well now they're
just three but if you somehow manage to
get rid of these pawns you could afford
at some point to trade uh and give up
your Bishop
because this is wrong this is going to
be a wrong Corner Bishop for the end
game obviously it's as white here you
never want to give up uh give up the
Rooks of course sometimes you do want to
give up lyrics but um yeah
it is a little bit tricky I feel that
white is gonna continue pressuring uh
time wise however Christopher has I
don't know if he's usually uh
able to keep this much time but he's
been able to manage his time very very
well yeah he's a little kid he can he
can turn on he's not that anymore he's
actually the junior champion
's junior Championship he played quite
well in the U.S championship last year
as well so absolutely yeah still still
pretty young
but yeah this is going to remain wait
there was another move that was played I
think King to G3 it looks like King G37
King U7 was played okay so he did not
give he did not play that well actually
this is nice this is nice to see where
the route goes and then you'll decide
whether you'll go F4 or not I think very
compact
I imagine it should go to H6 but I don't
know if it can stay there
I feel that black will have some ideas
of trading that Rook
should you choose I mean the problem
here for black is it's much easier to
defend along one diagonal so I think
that's maybe what you're kind of showing
is this bishop coming to F5 but with
this Pawn on F5 you you can't really get
the bishop to to G6 so easily and defend
all the pawns like this H7 Pawn is
always going to be loose until you can
get the bishop there but you think like
I said as long as black is able to
somehow get rid of these two pawns he
has
he has big chances to hold and yeah I
mean I think I think Christopher should
yes he should be able to hold and F4 is
on the board it's slightly worse but uh
for for black but he should be able to
hold let's go on to this other game
because this was interesting I thought
this was interesting as well
um
the pawn structure has changed a little
bit since
um we left off with Julian earlier
because now
White's last one was Queen D5 so he's
comfortable to make the trade
now if you trade you take back so you're
gonna have two pieces hanging yeah
losing is nothing at least the F7 Pawn
right
um
let's see
Knight here Rook takes F7
King G6 okay we have some we have this
move we should be perfectly fine yeah
we're not a huge fan of King G6 but
nude prefer King G8
so yeah so there's a pop down yeah it's
a pawn so it's black black might not be
so happy with that they might uh yeah
yeah he shouldn't it's not obligated to
take but uh where else does the Knight
go
right that's the problem that is the
problem it doesn't so he checked first
king H2 these moves were played and if
you could somehow take advantage maybe
this is an option potentially
but do you actually have something
because yes check let's let's check this
check check you can get to E2 with light
is that true
can you get to E2 without danger I think
so well I got this checked that was very
fancy G4 maybe luckily the queen is
protected especially with this Knight
here I think uh oh yeah no no there's a
reason I dropped out of this tournament
it's fine it's fine it's easy to forget
these kind of things you can maybe go to
G3 but I'm not so happy so the thing is
you could go there it could go 9g2 yeah
Knight G2 Queen H3 I thought might be a
problem so if you go to G3 first I
thought you might be okay
and then Knight G2 after reaching one
it's a little scary but you're up a
piece yeah I think
black yeah black would love to play like
G5 or something but it you just can't
you're gonna you don't have something
first yeah
so maybe that sacrifice doesn't work so
black would have to go into that end
game where the pawn down
um yeah it doesn't look so terrible to
be honest maybe you can play Rick D1 in
the final position so take take or do
one here
um 94 first day I think I think and then
uh now Rook D1
and you have a you have a lot of stuff
hanging with with white
we do but we also have an extra pun so
I'm thinking to push 496.
okay but that takes you from my F2 Pawn
let me go back and I take on C4
you want to be sneaky I thought I had
this move but 54 of this
it's very very loose but it just seems
like it's like Black is Black is pretty
active it's not over until it's over
okay you're right yes
I I should be able to yeah yeah because
you can play it even if I will have this
maybe I can take your opponents back but
I don't even have to you can do that
um
this this keeps on going the thing is
that I cannot play King F3 but because
there's this check let's check yeah very
unpleasant check feels like black people
hold together he seems like he will be
able to yeah yeah I think you definitely
just give up this Pawn on F7 and and uh
and try and recoup it
you can also play Rook C1 instead of
Rook D1 in some position yeah so Queen
takes D5 has been played I mean I think
you have to you're not just traps nine
days I mean 94 just makes the most sense
yeah to keep everything under attack and
then after Rook F7 if you don't play
Rook F7 I'm not sure you can try and win
with just the C Pawn I guess but
it's difficult and then no you have to
take that pawn you're also weakening
this one if you go Rook D1 maybe Knight
E3 could be an issue but I wanted to
just play Rook C1 in that position here
so Rick d one first okay yeah that's
what I thought so this is our line right
so now you want to no here Knight D6 was
was good enough I think yeah I think
this was you can play like Knight F6
check at some point but I just don't
think it's it's gonna do the job
no because you can play King G6 and I
think yeah I thought maybe Rook C7
and then some Knight F6 yeah so Rook C7
first oh okay
so we're saying Knight takes C4 here you
can throw in this check but I honestly
don't think it really helps here either
like okay maybe 98 is this like a
problem
I think this king is gonna run away this
looks like something no this looks like
a pretty serious problem though right
okay I don't need to go too no I have to
go to G6
Knights attacked
maybe maybe it's not so simple
yeah I mean I'll just take G7 with check
oh you want to go that way yeah and uh
okay it's it's a pawn
but the pawns are connected it's not
going to be very easy you can go rookie
seven here
your knight is also somewhat trapped
it's not going to be
a piece of cake to get it out of there I
want to play for mates somehow but it's
not so easy yeah Knight G7 is no good
yet and maybe just F3
I want to try to get rid of my Pawn
if I can yeah I mean black might
definitely survive you do have this but
every time you give me this check I have
yeah and then you have to move the Rook
far away you know but it is a pawn I I
might have played some awkward moves
with white here
um but maybe you know if I if I were
playing with black and I saw this line
and I go down this Pawn I wouldn't be
super happy this is the current position
by the way these moves were played so
can we just play Rook C1 and take that
pawn directly
that is an option that is a move
like someone was saying I want to play
for the mate since you already gave me
the idea I might as well just take it we
can show this line oh yeah of course for
the audience it's a nice nice kind of
mate you can throw in King G8 I guess
should have to and now where do we move
if I kept my Rook on the f file I still
maintain that threat yeah this looks
very very nasty like 97 to G6 is
you know pretty upsetting you could go
night yeah but it's not really it's all
right you might just get
checkmated very very quickly after yeah
f8 Knight G6 not sure you have any time
here
this is tough does the stuff but okay H5
is a pretty big threat no I did like
your first idea though Rook D1 attacking
that Knight first because this forces
you have to shake some things loose
I think it's kind of forces C4 going
back you could go back and then if Rook
C1
um oh sorry sorry for C1 you can go C4 I
guess
but maybe Rook D3 is the idea instead of
Rexy one yeah because registry you'll
have the capture here too right
um
can I take maybe maybe Knight F5 is is
good though no uh King G6 okay
you don't
yes is it over I don't know if it's over
yet we still have some amazing ideas I
mean this idea with H5 is something that
white definitely has I definitely don't
super love it for black
it just feels like we should have some
simple way right
some simpler way to do these kinds of
things okay so this is the current
position that we can think at some other
moves
but one yeah I think D1 Rook D1 seems
like the most forcing for sure this is
another one um you definitely want to do
something about this Knight F6 idea and
especially with this this H5 but there's
no actual Threat by white just yet or is
this a threat or is this a threat I'm
thinking since H5 always is trying to
mate us maybe we could just try to play
King G6 or
um or H5 yeah I mean the thing is like
white might not have a severe threat but
uh they're up a pawn
you know the threat maybe yeah of course
if white can consolidate the C Pawn is
going to cause some real real problems
their daughter is going for the win at
first when when this game started it
just seemed that he's just skipping the
the game balance and going for some
equality or something but then after
that you know nothing nothing uh
well we skipped a lot of the Moses yeah
we're directly into the end game now I'm
glad we're definitely found some ways to
pose problems to say the least so yeah I
think uh Jacobson will spend most of his
remaining time here because this is no
oh no he's gonna move night of six weeks
what okay so this is is this possible
yeah this is more little kid tactics
Okay so if we take their skin G6 and now
when you move the Rook somewhere he's
gonna take and he thinks that four
versus three
you think it's easy I don't think it's
so easy uh I I don't know if he thinks
it's easy but at the judging by the
lines we were looking at how would you
capture
um I think you should take with uh with
the pawn here I think that this Pawn on
E5 is
is a bigger weakness than the pawn on H6
um
if that makes sense like you would
rather have e5b stronger defended than
the pawn on H6 in my opinion but uh
I've been wrong before so I'm kind of
worried about your king that's why I was
asking you because I think well did you
have to G4 H5 yes yeah but you have to
be mindful about these ideas yeah
because so my understanding of of these
end games is black should try to create
a past Pawn
um which is going to be very difficult
unless you think this is gonna work you
could theoretically play F5 in this
position
and lose all your Pawns you are
definitely yes definitely aggressive
you're definitely aggressive
um
I get it
again
um but I I don't know about that F5 I
think you could try to create your past
Pawn I'm just worried this is an option
of course so you have created your past
Pawn but it's not going to be as
powerful because white has two further
away possible so that's going to be an
issue yeah I think you know the idea is
we want to distract White's rook and if
we can trade off our e-pawn for the C
Pawn then our job is going to be so so
much easier so right maybe we can try
and get something like that but it's
maybe we could take with the King too in
that position it's certainly not not
trivially drawn and it might not be that
might not be drawn at all after some
time I would prefer this one better I
like this better because I'm thinking if
if we get the chance to play G5 and
trade off these pawns even if at some
point you know we might lose another one
so I I think White's gonna play your
move G4 in every position still yeah and
if you go G5 I'll go H5 and then you
have some real real problems
necessarily because I I want to go
um E4 and I want to try to get my king
in this way and when you come this way
I'll give you checks in the back but you
don't have so much time right I can go
King G3 mm-hmm oh I can't okay so you
said when I go G5 G5 H5 you might be
able to give me a couple of checks
because you want to go H5 okay then I'll
give you this check King H2 or sorry H3
okay it's not it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter I wouldn't take it I
wouldn't you wouldn't take it I would I
would I would I would say
um yeah and now I I just
want so you need to start marching this
maybe I should start with with King G2
to be honest okay sure but the problem
is when your king is in G2 then you have
this entrance so I changed my mind yeah
so no no I still like it King H3 Rook C1
King H3 sorry Rook C1
um so my whole point is I just wanted to
play Rook H7 but I'm hanging my Pawn
with check but I don't care this time
are you sure about that so I guess
you're getting into F4 just just in time
right I am so I'll take on H6
I'm not gonna win this I promise you
maybe you're gonna lose in the best case
well what if I go
you take me I go H6 and then H7
I'm not really sure how you want to win
because you know I can just place my
Rook on Seventh Rank and just keep your
Pawn attacked once you get it there okay
and luckily I still have this Pawn which
means F3 I'll take I think I can do this
so H7
I think I could be wrong oh you're gonna
bring your king behind your Rook so you
go Rook H6 actually I could do both I
could 57 I wasn't convinced because can
I just win the E2 to E3 right yeah I saw
that idea I'm just thinking I could just
go there and then just go grab your Pawn
aha
I believe you okay okay good all right
good
well
so my impression of both games white is
trying to win but black is trying to not
lose so you know everything up in the
air it's still up in the air the players
are approaching time control can you
tell us about the location the the
tournament uh also what do you think
about Jacob's interviews did you have
the time to watch some of those
interviews
um yes the tournament is on the St Louis
University
um it's not really directly on campus
I'm not sure if it's still technically
on the grounds or not but it's at IL
monastero it's uh which I guess is Latin
for the monastery it basically looks
like an old church and where there's
plenty of space chess club brought some
snacks and drinks for the players we're
well cared for I also saw a lot of the
pictures by uh the by Austin and I've
noticed a lot of pictures in the intro
of the show guess I didn't make the cut
but that's okay that's all right
everyone if they want to watch the the
pictures there on Saint Lucia's club's
Flickr page right so that's that's a
great way to you know check out some
very intense pictures I I've checked
some out and I thought they were they
were great yeah they always do great
jobs yeah yeah um but no the tournament
I think has been going pretty smoothly
so far
um do you have a peek on who may win
this tournament based on these two games
that you saw and that's it you know
they're not even over yet we don't know
what's gonna happen but yeah I think
I'll get your peek we should have done
that I don't know why we didn't judging
from from today you know obviously
Christopher has black and Theodore as
white but
uh this is definitely the type of end
game that that white wins uh a lot of
the time
um it's going to take some some very
very accurate play from black to to
survive
um now you managed to do it in whatever
line we were just in okay but it's
different when you're playing instead of
instead of me that's right well don't
don't be so tough on yourself I think
yeah no I honestly Theodore has very
decent chances to get a full point here
and then obviously that would that would
catapult him into Soul first which would
because I don't think Christopher's ever
gonna yeah against uh prison here and he
possibly will get the next an extra
white in the last round so that's gonna
be a good good way whereas Christopher
might have the black pieces we don't
know but it was great having you here
yeah anything else no thanks for having
me on I just wanted to come say hi talk
about a little chess
but I will give the reins back to Julian
all right well I appreciate you joining
us
um I hope we'll see you again very soon
if not you guys know where to check out
some of Caleb's videos oh yeah thanks
very much I've got my own YouTube
channel now I upload uh once every five
months so mark your calendars for the
next video
um and again thank you very much for for
having me on I will see you guys see you
guys soon all right thank you Caleb
double elimination starts Friday for the
American Cup
Friday March 17th and it's going to
start at 1pm Central Time the commentary
might start a little bit earlier than
that we have grand Masters Yasser Saron
Christian kirilla and international
master and very strong female chess
player Ivanka Huska so I cannot wait for
that tournament I don't know about you
guys
but this tournament still has this round
to end and then we'll have
uh well
another round in the afternoon they were
not really going over unfortunately but
you guys can always check out the games
and results on the
leeches.org page going back into this
game between Nicolas deodoro and Brandon
Jacobson looks like a couple more moves
were played since Caleb and I discussed
this position Knight of six and then C4
as I'm joined back by my wonderful
co-host uh Julian for Lego hi back
Julian how are you feeling being back
good yeah get to see some exciting or
not so exciting chess
Happening Here with with this
interesting end game that
um we you and I when we started talking
about this game I think we never thought
that this could happen right yeah it's
just pretty equal before we left right
and now now Theodore is definitely for
choice
seems yeah and uh I Caleb and I were
were talking earlier about this move
Knight of six that black played right
Caleb uh suggested this move Rook D1
that I thought was quite interesting but
um
Brandon went for Knight F6 and out of
Knight F6
the capture did not happen although I
thought that position would give white
maybe some chances
um 906 is a very very fancy move right
it's great to consider yeah
so probably uh go after a king G6 Rook
C7 that we were suggesting probably King
takes was a good choice for black
obviously black is not going to win this
but
um but I think this well what are your
thoughts about this position would you
have taken with the g-pawn or King If
This Were to be played yeah I I don't
really I don't think I can really say
without like thinking about it for a few
minutes it was it's definitely like a
hard decision right yeah you have to
spend some time obviously
um it's it's a rook end game so anything
can happen but
intuitively I guess like Pawn takes
makes more sense to me but I mean it
definitely does have this downside of
like G4 and and all your pawns can get
fixed and weak yeah that's that's what I
was worried about because even H5 is
good but then when you're making the
trade you're actually leaving white with
this further away past one that could be
very annoying so yeah but that did not
happen so we don't need to worry too
much about it C4 was played and then
um black flater looks to B2
yeah in this position
a funny trick black could have could
have played now granted you know these
are all tricks so you shouldn't play
this way but black could have played
Rook B3 if you're trying you know if
you're playing bullet you'd play Rook B3
right because you're threatening Knight
G4 which leads to checkmate
so uh if Knight F6 isn't like a concern
right now Rook B3 is uh is a candidate
move I suppose it's kind of
like you know if you play some passive
improving move like I don't know it's
actually every Improvement move stops my
threat but my threat right now is Knight
G4 check King G1 Rook V1 yeah yeah it's
really it's really not so subtle yeah
yeah let's just make some silly move
to show that sorry about it I was
reading the chat and I was I got a
little bit distracted there for a second
they want to see how costia won his game
against Balaji I believe
um that's uh that's a result that I
think just came in
um but but this is this is really nice I
mean this game
is this game gonna end in a draw I don't
even know what to say
yeah definitely Brandon would be pretty
happy if this game ended in it of course
of course he's slightly worse in this
position
um could we play F3 or is this too much
to ask
I think F3 has some good positional
Foundation
he may he may consider going Rook C2 and
trying to get the C Pawn I think it's
important to get this one since it's the
furthest away past pawn and then usually
you can deal with you know a possible
even if you have one down if your king
is in front of it but this remains
remains to be seen Let's uh let's go
really fast and see how costly I was
able to take down Grandmaster Balaji
dagupati did you have a chance to look
at the game at all no no breaks no
breaks no brakes there was a longer
break but unfortunately
there was a meeting yeah an all-staff
meeting yes attend
oh I actually know this one this is
interesting that's incredible this is
this is very interesting I was just
curious the 95 is not the usual move
here I think I played something like
this one time
um it says it's the main
are arguably
one of oh actually so so normally uh so
I play H3 here Bishop H5 and then Knight
C3 and then after E6 G4 now G4 yeah I
think I played a game like this this is
supposed to be really good for white
yeah arguably the best game I ever
played was against Michael molier
um where I just like I just crushed him
with prep in this exact line okay
um I have very fond memories of this
line it's Knight D7 and the Knight G6 HG
G5
uh the point of G5 is the black position
only wants to play G5 so you stop him
the Knight E4
yeah take take g5s hanging so you have
to play H4 so then Bishop before
disposition looks a little bit scary for
black yeah so if you just give white two
Bishops he's happy so Bishop B4 to trade
it off Queen A5
uh and black actually there's a threat
here Black's thread is 95 which wins the
game which is hard to see
because if you take it then Castle's
Queen side that's just this material
that is nice so if you play some okay A3
I guess yes so A3 is is the main move
yeah so if we put some strange move for
white I don't even know what yeah like
okay let's just put some strange sure
that's terrible but okay takes long
castle and the thing is you're pinned
you're double pinned like a cross pin in
a way and there's nothing to maybe I
happen to have put a decent move because
I think I have F4 here but anyways no no
it still works because F4 I take on D2
with the Rook oh and then I play oh and
then you put the other okay okay so you
think you escape but no but even number
some probably would have created some
some unpleasantries for for white but
yeah okay this is nice yes game over
nice idea
yeah so I guess they have to play
something
A3 yeah A3 and it's Bishop D2 Queen D2
Queen D2 King D2 and then so in the
current position white now has a threat
which is Bishop G2 because if you play
F5 after Bishop G2 I'll take it off a
sign then you're left with this horrible
Pawn structure so you play F5 right away
to stop Bishop G2 but uh you don't take
now with why do you no no so I'm saying
if you play like keaney 7 or something
for instance then white goes Bishop G2
and if you play F5 yeah then take you
have to take and yeah you have to take
with the knife which is which is not
great this would be terrible for the
poor black pawn structure okay right so
they play F5 right away before Bishop G2
can be played and so you don't take here
because you're an opening fixes their
Pawn structure so then C5 and this is
like the starting position with a lot of
ideas the point of C5 is yeah you gain
space and you also stop Knight B6 to D5
so a big fan of this variation for white
very nice for white
if black doesn't get any breaks with E5
or F4 it's just probably what he's gonna
try to do but whenever he does that he
does end up weakening you know these
pawns specifically G6 that's probably
going to be tough yeah I mean it's not
like lost for black or anything but it's
just so pleasant to play with white
um but Christopher or sorry not
Christine kavutski chose like maybe an
improvement over this he's like trying
to improve on a line that's already
considered to be good for white so so
he's two to six 92. she's claiming the
Knight is better on D2 than C3
well
It's Tricky
no sometimes people play 92
um either to try because the idea still
should be E4 potentially unless black is
going to play E5 like it happened in the
game but I feel that if this is played
you go Bishop G2 and then your plan is
going to be to play E4
um and trade there and you'll have the
bishop pair and
um and typically eventually after you
castle and everything you will have a
plan to eventually break open the
position with D5 it takes a while I
think there are a few good games that
were played in that with that break idea
but
um so it doesn't technically matter
where you put the Knight but
yeah I guess the advantage of having the
Knight on D2 over C3 is the DC4 is never
like really an idea anymore
if we put the Knight on C3 and we play
Bishop G2 then black could definitely
consider capturing the C4 upon itself at
some moment that's right yeah you would
get it back but it takes more time but
with the night there that's a thing and
I think
um the plans like I said are still with
E4 just the the problem is that
blackplay D5 directly so that was which
that's interesting I guess highlights
why the night would be worse on D2 right
because if the Knight we're on C3 then
you control D5 and you would be left
with some isolated Pawn on D5 but now
now it's not so easy
so we still took took took and he left
the pawn
oh he okay so he's still good he kept
her with the pawn but I mean if Knight
were to take I think we had probably
some ideas before yeah
and this check we have Bishop D2 so we
should be fine and I think White
wouldn't be scared to Castle short side
in this position with the bishop in G2
protecting H3 you don't really have an
easy way to to attack white skin
okay so it's let's go on with the game
so Knight C6 G5 whoa okay he decided to
go for the attack without finishing his
development that's
interesting
a lot of people
fear castling because they see The Rook
still on the H file they see the bishop
and the diagonal all open but I think
you know if you if you calculate a
little bit you realize that
it takes black a couple of moves to
actually get to H2 so you probably have
sufficient time to play native yeah the
thing I was concerned about a little bit
was D4 instead of um uh in instead of
moving the bishop but it's a little
nonsense because if you play e takes
here then potentially I can play like
Knight takes G4 because I've because
I've blocked your Queen's defense over
the G4 square but then it comes here but
uh yeah I mean I don't have such good
development
probably and even this position if you
take it's probably a draw
you think no no for Bishop H2 it's
perpetual right
no way you have a mate do you have a
mate
I I didn't calculate if I do it's by
luck
I don't know if you do you might
maybe not
because of nine of day okay never mind I
don't take it I don't take it I was
actually thinking of taking things right
but yeah I was thinking of Fate I was
thinking about doing that in the
previous position before like instead of
taking on D4 like Bishop takes C6 like
this probably
it takes
okay king of fate and then the queen
would come back here yeah worst case
Queen comes back to G2 and then wears
Black's compensation oh what I know well
I will take an E3 what will you do about
this character and Effie
so you go back here now or yeah yeah
Queen G2 Maybe
okay I'll definitely
I'll definitely take care
okay if I go Queen B6 you have Knight C4
yeah and I can't go Queen E7 because my
Rook is hanging
yeah I mean also Queen B6 Queen A8 right
so it's hard to move the Queen off the
the eighth rank
to bring in my Rook first
right so 94 oh it might be too much yeah
94 takes takes takes on H3 yeah and then
queen queen G6 I know I think I'm gonna
go to page one I'm just gonna go for it
like yeah you can't take because Queen
H4 and then yeah yeah it's me yeah
that is me but you don't need to take
the Rook necessarily however King G2 but
then Rook C2 oh no the queen Gardens
backwards the queen huh
no I got this Rick H2 yeah but you come
back at the very least it's perpetual
but no I feel like we should have more
than oh oh wait wait I know I know Roxy
too yeah take and then Rick H2 yeah
that's nice
um
okay this is very messy I'm sure we've
messed up a little bit oh yeah for sure
um but it's an interesting line to show
anyways uh so what did you suggest here
oh I I just suggested a nonsense
tactical variation so maybe maybe D4 is
interesting it is interesting I agree
and
they calculated and at the board with
around our 30
it's gonna be
um a little bit crazy by the way you
just see we got a result in the game
Lazada brazon against Christopher you so
it remains to be seen if Nicolas
Theodore is going to be able to take
down Brandon Jacobson to take the lead
in this Super Summer super Swiss
absolutely good result for Christopher
right he was sort of suffering in that
game I think yeah he was suffering a
little bit with um
with the um the pawn structure he had a
lot of Pawns blocked on light square or
the light Square Bishop it was a little
bit
of an issue but
okay you want to check out the oh oh
sorry I just wanted to scroll through
let's see let's see the blunder that
happened because it seems quite natural
it's very sharp all right so long Castle
was an option but Queen F5 was played
and the engine said that this was a
blunder let's try to figure out why
mm-hmm
well it seems just so natural but I
guess because the king is in the center
white has some way to defend
it's so hard not to like look at the
moves and Justice
I didn't even press it but it was
pressed before someone pressed to
analyze this game unfortunately we can't
get rid of the analysis once it's there
I think
but
um Queen B5 is what caused airplane so
this might be important so the point the
point must be that like I don't know why
F4 doesn't also win by the way but Queen
no actually maybe I do no okay so like
Knight C6 here Queen B7 wins right so
maybe this also wins but the point is
like Queen B5 attacks the D3 Knight so
like F4 and you chase one night away and
then capture the other one so
seems pretty convincing
wait a second what if I don't wanna what
if I don't want to move the night is it
possible that I could play this strange
wait so if I take on E5 you have I just
I just have a check I don't think
I don't think I have more I saw one
check
and you know what they say a Revenge
check yes yeah just one check and then
good old spite check yeah no there's
nothing this king is in the center but
there's nothing we can do about it maybe
white Skin's safer than black skin
surrounded by all his army most pieces
people are seeing if
Thrive but why is this woman
so Queen B5 was played in the game but
oh wait Knight takes
Knight takes takes Queen now I have more
checks more spikes for shakes two you
have two I got this one Bishop C5 yeah
so okay hold on I'm actually I'm I'm
like blind so you have to help me out so
Bishop C5 can F2 King G2 where's the
next check no I did I did it just so I I
just said it has more checks than the
previous ones I just went for the line
sorry uh because I'm threatening Queen
B5 check and I'm up a piece yeah so the
position is
it's not clear to me at least
that's right I got this but then yeah
yeah I I don't know
[Music]
um
why is Queen B5 so so important it's not
no I I thought I would give one more
check maybe I don't need to uh well now
you want to take this Knight too I I
don't know how many pieces black can
afford to give up in this position I
know White's underdeveloped here but I
don't think it's gonna be
good to give that many pieces away maybe
yeah
wreckage Rook H3
maybe give something okay you can always
just take take and take on E5 even
yeah I mean I I don't think a lot of
materials yeah way too much
I can't I guess you decided to give this
check first
and then F4 I don't think it matters you
just try to avoid potentially just that
track right he could have given it later
too
and then A6 was played right
Knight AC one was hard to come up with
with ways here with black but giving up
this night for that doesn't seem
like the right thing to do because
you're just why he played A6 first
instead of Knight takes C1
because after Queen B7 A8 is hanging but
if you take on C1 now it seems like
superficially we're solving some of our
issues even if our position doesn't look
great like that that's going to hang it
anyways but I agree A6 just seems like
oh I guess your Queen's trapped oh
that's no no it's not no it's not
um I think we're still oh wait wait but
if you take there you can take here with
the bishop yeah that I mean that end
game looks horrible for black how many
extra pawns do I have two only two I
mean two is enough is this yeah it just
feels like it's so many more and that
drug is out of play you know yeah and if
you go Rook C8 then Rook oh sorry Rook
be it Rook C8 here like the position has
to be pretty dead for black yeah I can
try to be oops sorry about that I didn't
mean to make that move
you're meaner than I am yeah it was
Sabine is a mean mean
mode yeah sometimes she just wants to
sacrifice everything taking all your you
can even at night C6 it can save all
your people oh right all right yeah I
forgot it I thought I could do it
earlier but I didn't see there was a
check yeah so I think still you get oh
you get to take it here I don't know if
they have a couple more chicks but
anyways this is this is really bad so so
yeah took that pawn and then seems like
there are a few checks but once you put
the knight in front it's kind of over
for the checks Knights are usually known
to defend a king very well against the
queen checks and then he just
cruise through so Victor black never had
the option of like moving his Knight to
D3 because always there was some
Checkmate being threatened either on F7
or A8 right so
nice game by Costa really nice yeah
congrats to costia I don't know if we're
gonna get interviews today or not we
were not told yet it's been a little bit
on an unusual day we're waiting on it to
see but it's been a little bit it's been
a little bit hectic at the chess club
but that's okay that's okay
um we're back with this so when uh Caleb
was here we were looking around this
position I just wanted to see how the
players ended up drawing this so
um the past few moves Christopher
brought in his King closer to restrict
that Rook away and then he had this move
F4 that I thought white was trying to
stop by bringing the king to F4 but
black whistle to be faster so after
pushing that the trade happened and now
although you gave up a pawn is just
gonna be hard for white to progress this
position because everything is
um you know black oh and Costa is
watching the the stream good job nice
game nice game we're liked we liked your
game thanks for following us
um so Rook F7
by the way there was a delay so that's
why he's probably in the chat we do have
a delay in the game she didn't just
finish but make something we don't know
if he was interviewed or not we were not
told
um about that but okay so oh so I guess
okay so Christopher now is coming back
to protect that pawn before grabbing
that one I guess
or could he not have taken it
I think he could have right yeah I think
he just didn't want to trade what seems
to be like a weak double death Pawn for
the H Pawn like why even give white this
option it's not necessary I guess since
anytime you go King G3 we'll have Rook
G7 check and then Rook back but Bishop
H5 chasing that Rook away and then
okay rodden the king oh nice I love E3
okay getting rid of the other more pawns
also it might might not seem important
right now but it is the wrong color yes
it is so if we trade Rooks and I
sacrifice my Bishop for the F Pawn then
I can never lose
I should have made that another color
so did you notice the difference so
you're not able you're not able to lose
that position no matter what
and oh they uh but I don't know it's now
it's not so difficult even if you lose
this yeah yeah that's what I was gonna
say but that's hard that's hard that
takes a while to practice that position
I think it's in 100 end games you must
know
um there are a few variations and it
explains to you how you should do it and
such it's of course then again manual
and pretty much all end game manuals out
there but yeah this is
yeah it's definitely not an end game you
want to have practically yeah you might
forget something and just mess something
up
I wouldn't be a hundred percent
confident but the moves happen so fast
I'm really surprised because I mean how
could they have played so many moves is
this game not over no no the game the
game is over
okay they just played like incredibly
fast and just made the moves and then
okay yeah I don't think they had to play
till still made but I guess some some
tournaments have this role that you need
to play at least
30 moves or sometimes you are not
allowed to offer a draw but do you want
to check out this uh The Thief game
against Dennis since we haven't like
looked at it yet sure yeah
oh and more Rook end games Moroccan
games yeah yeah I guess this is chess is
all about working yes we haven't had
that many
um the previous days Doug how did they
arrive into this position there's a rook
Bishop versus Rook Knight
and
um I do like white in that final
position
I just wanted to see how the bishop was
given up for the night
okay
defense and now he decided to give it up
and he did not take the pawn in G7
because
so this requires a lot of calculation it
does I suppose your King's just not very
strong
probably
some drawings this should be a draw yeah
so instead King U6 Rook B5 yeah it's a
nice move because C4 is kind of weak
right it's a nice restricting move
because you keep black skin cut off from
the pond so it cannot come to protect it
and the same time you're keeping this
Rook of Black's passive to protect that
pawn and you're keeping your own
weakness protected now A Simple Plan for
right would be to just bring in the King
which I think is going to be very easy
now danish needs to activate that Rook
fast the problem is when you get on the
D file we'll just capture the pawn and
whenever you play say a rook to D2 to
attack it we'll be right back or coming
right back
so you don't really have the opportunity
to activate your Rook
yeah I I think black's defensive task
here is going to be really tough to be
honest with you I do not envy black
people to try to to trade these pawns
faster you can move with the King on
this other side of the board right even
if you lose upon like if you were to get
rid of all three versus these two
although that you're most likely gonna
lose because White's really yeah getting
that honestly I think what black should
try to do and this is like almost
impossible is trade the F Pawn for the G
Pawn
and then try to get counter play against
the H5 Pawn but how it's yeah it's like
G6
oh it did a loud check yeah yeah
yeah this this does not look good for
good for black well at least he
succeeded in doing one thing and that is
he was able to get his Rook
away from passivity so now he gets it
that's true but the point uh the reason
why the Rook was passive was it had to
defend all these pawns and still has to
defend all these pawns so I I don't I
don't know I think black might just be
busted here to be honest with you
yeah Keen takes it's so it's so many
things obviously yeah now we're
searching me but but now there might be
some checks Keena five check can you see
six maybe I'm sure play King is 16. or
maybe even I don't know like maybe we
don't like lakina four after Rook D5
check and then you go back to take my G6
pawn and I take your A5 or C4 pawn and
that end game should be pretty winning
yeah
[Music]
or there
yeah I think it's just really tough
okay this is the current position but
I think there are brand name may be
winning this game
all right so you wanted to check on
theodoru and Jacobson antipo of one
against Corrales that was an interesting
but yeah let's let's stay on that game
okay well a lot of a lot has changed
yeah very much has changed this game
um that pawn became a d-pawn it used to
be C Pawn
capture that's how it happened
of course how else would it have
happened magically appeared on the
default yeah if it weren't a capture I
want to call the Arbiter
well I've seen I've seen pieces just end
up on other squares and Blitz Games but
obviously this is not a blades game
players have quite a lot of time left
I mean sufficient that they can have uh
time to make the right decisions so
let's see kimchi sex King F7
d7's interesting this seven is
interesting I think he is trying to
avoid The Lion King his sex because
after that you can take but here if you
go there I think he wants to go here now
you can't go back because we promote so
you need to take with the King because
with the Rook we would just trade and
lose the king I'm hunting and right
that's fast and then here Rook G7 Rook
G5 yeah
and that pawn is going to be lost
it's very little chances for draw so
Rook D5 is played
so now with white if you want to
progress one way would be to go rookie
shade or Rook d8
I just realized maybe a black is in a
lot of trouble
um bring the king yeah because this is
like a permanent thing you can't play G6
because if you play G6 where KJ wins
and or wait actually Rook h8 wins
whenever actually no but but if you
bring the king closer it will win yeah
but wait are you in time so like King G1
and then black plays G6 right away and
then Rook uh oh you still do this okay
yes I bring my king and then keaney
seven rookie shade
um oh you go I think I should go root G8
because I need to get something
if you take the Rook though at first I
was gonna trade but I don't think I
trade here I think I just take your Pawn
First Richie five or okay
and if you go you can sorry you can't
you can't you can do anything here to
protect you lose one yeah this should be
lost
so your blanking is six
well he can get the Jeep on now so he
has to take the h
M yeah and he's kind of forced into it
intuitively I would say that this end
game is drawn
so I think I was wrong earlier when I
said that black wasn't like a lot of
trouble I mean he has to these ones if
this was here maybe it was easier but I
think this is hard to draw
because
um
I have various ways of improving this
position although if your E4 if you
don't get E4
what if I just like wait what is your
what is your winning plan I guess I I
first need to understand if E4 is a good
possibility for black or not yeah I
don't I don't really want to play E4 if
you can
if you don't have to trade I just want
to sit on the position
if I can
you don't want to play before I see I
mean if I trade pawns then I might well
I definitely need my Rook to be improved
so I'll go here it's like Rook A4 here
and work before
okay
now five
king of five
I'm gonna cut you off
always cutting me off ridiculous I don't
know uh you do you really need to play
this at some point you think okay now I
might not before I was afraid of Rook A5
yeah
and I felt like you were going to beat
me here
and it was going to be sad
yeah yeah I will get that pawn back
okay so what do you want to do I don't
know like Rook B2 or something
I said I can give you
that was too much I can always go back
I'll just go here like Rook C2
I just want to see if I can play the
position with waiting
I I needed to are you gonna play G6
um no I'll play can't have sex okay
great
because I wanted to push so I needed to
know you needed to know what I was up to
no yeah but Rook C3 you can do that so
I'm gonna go King G2 so I can play a
four okay
and then my progress
okay Rook C3 check
ing of seven hmm
I don't know it's definitely suffering
but I don't know if I should lose
I'm gonna play this for a while
oh I agree uh five yeah
yeah now
I'm not as afraid as I once was I think
because
um E4
no that's the thing I was I was hoping
to do that because you can't you still
can't I can't play E4 I didn't think so
but now I realize you have this move
yeah and what is going on exactly here
are you gonna Checkmate me yeah I have
you're just you're committing me here
yeah
uh uh yeah so this is not possible but
after
yeah okay so I can't play wow I can't
play E4 after rookie yeah that's why I'm
thinking that black and I'll play four
because you have the same so let's say I
wait like
um
Rook B3 for instance
so I do want to progress the thing is I
can't have both my Rook here to cover to
bring my king to G4 and my Rook behind
to push you to G6 right that's the only
problem as to why I was trying to decide
whether I should push G500 might be too
soon
it's a like a huge thing there
um yeah I mean I was always taught in
these sorts of end games that you
usually don't like as the defensive side
you want to trade pawns when you can and
when you when you can't you should just
try to wait and
make white figure out a way to make
progress
I mean
physician yeah I feel like a lot of I
don't know a lot of beginners the way
that they get in trouble and these like
3v2 end games is they with the defensive
side they just push their pawns up the
board really fast and then they get into
trouble because they have all these
weaknesses that they can't defend
and uh and that's tough but sometimes
patience patience pays off I don't know
what happened in the game though because
I guess uh yeah maybe I shouldn't play
G5 maybe that was I think I could play
H5
um yeah first and then I I definitely
need to get my two pawns there it's just
no matter of how you get it now you're
threatening Rook A6 King G5 and then 56
main yeah which is nice
uh so so I guess
um so a funny line a way that black
could lose would be like King G5 Rook A6
E4 Rook G6 this would be a highly
unfortunate way for the game to end
uh I you can't play G6 and you can't
play E4 maybe you can't have seven
so I was trying now G5 yeah this is the
thing yeah I was trying to get this I
just can't E6 instead or so sorry uh
instead of Keno seven hold up maybe
there's some can be like slightly clever
like you can try to hold on but I think
I have two checks check first
uh you then I won't have the control
over the fourth rank okay let's see so
check yeah go there I will G5 so you
need to cover this right oh it's gonna
play oh you want to go E4 you can I hope
so
I don't want to play the position if I
can't play E4 let's put it like that
um okay
it kind of does
hmm
too bad
okay I could get mated by G6 King James
that's an important move actually Chuck
cannot fade back yeah
well I was hoping you'd play that wait
this is one of those um Fortress
positions right King King G8 if you stay
on the file Rook F3 and then takes as a
draw ramp yeah
yeah
I tried yeah I tried it didn't work but
but you have to push I mean definitely
when you have this kind of position you
have to push it looks like he's he's
changing it a little bit so he brought
in the king to E3 so he's still getting
that idea okay so he's still got my idea
with the King there but now I don't know
if you must have rushed it with it a
little bit because now there's E4
well it's white it's white to play so
yeah I know but uh how do you stop
before
uh if you don't have a hiding spot the
way I did it I was hiding so there's
never an E4 as an option maybe he wants
Rook F5 and just
just like
um it's hard to make a move here but is
this winning the king and pawn if we get
the king and pawn end game do we win
this we should I think should yeah
because he's going to be the pawn on
Fifth do we go there that gets traded
and it's a Pawn on the magical rank so
then this is fine
this is fine then we can go Rook of fate
he's gonna go here he can't go E4 right
because and uh oh he can can he what
wait Ricky for a rookie it I mean why is
this possible no it's not okay okay I
panicked okay King seven
yeah
I don't know probably the game's just
gonna end into in a draw it was my
assumption
yeah we can't progress I guess I could
play here
and play here
UAE four
can I do this or is that a draw
um wait wait I know you can take with
the pawn I know you can take with the
pawn okay
um I thought this was this was your this
is my plan yeah
so I you can but I don't think it's good
I think this is
seems pretty easy for my twin
no
uh
uh okay so if I go Kenny seven here and
you go King G6 and I play Rook H5
oh sorry sorry Rook A4 my bet no Rook A4
and then G5 and I go Rook H4 how do you
oh you go Rook F7
oh yeah you just take okay no you just
won okay fair enough so I have to take
with you you have to take the Rook yeah
so takes and now I'm trying to figure
out if this same game is winning or not
I don't think I've ever seen this
particular one should be winning as well
yeah but let's see is it really because
you need to get the right kind of
opposition I don't think you're winning
because like here
this is a draw
can we when if we go from the other side
uh but how do we go he's gonna get King
G5 okay so he wins he goes there and go
here and here this is a drum yeah
okay well
then there's gonna be a draw
we can put this thing yeah
to check
this is the this is the position
um
yeah it's definitely definitely hard for
white to make progress
okay so we are not getting extra moves
here it's possible the players have a
great on a draw we don't know however
that that
has happened
okay as we are waiting as we are waiting
on that I just want to remind all of you
guys that uh
something new is starting in San Luis
we're going to have the American Cup
uh hopefully we can pull a flyer for the
competition oh no you guys aren't
it's a two double elimination tournament
uh 16 competitors 10 days of Chess you
guys can see it I'm not gonna read it
from the screen that would be too much
but it's going to be an amazing
tournament uh
eight players in the female Section 8 in
the mail section all top
players in the country and there's going
to be commentary
by some very awesome people that I enjoy
watching all the time myself those will
be grand Masters Christian kirilla
Yasser seron the one and only and
international Master yvanka Huska so
hopefully you guys will be around to
watch that it starts on Friday right at
1pm so that's gonna be really exciting
be sure to tune in on Twitch and YouTube
for live commentary of course YouTube or
twitch and of course you can check out
the standings pairings and more
information about the event on U.S chess
Champs Dot
.com
I was I was waiting I was waiting on
all right so it seems we got a
confirmation that the players agreed on
a draw I think Toyota kind of missed
some chances here to play for a win with
this idea he kind of got his Rook
stuck there yeah these
let's take a look at the results guys
seems like we have them already although
not everything was updated on the site
okay so a draw on the top three boards
uh which means the uh the Chris for you
and Nicholas theodoru are still leading
uh by half a point going into the um the
eighth round but they were caught up by
Raza harshit right oh yeah his game so
we will have three people time for first
for the last
last two rounds yeah that's gonna be
exciting
lots of lots of other draws I've said
there had been the one finally that end
game that we showed earlier against
tennis Ballers yeah that end game looked
really really tough for Dennis it did it
seemed equal because the material is
equal but just because you see equal
material it doesn't mean it's going to
end in a draw that's a really good take
away from from this tournament I guess
and of course this game was very nice we
were not told about any interview that
was able to be taken by the players
unfortunately
so I think
I don't know is there any other game we
could go over that we didn't go over was
there any question in your chat I think
all the games all the games happen to be
happen to be done
um well what do you say shall we call it
a day for today Julian it was kind of a
short day for us actually it was a short
expected date
mostly due to our extended break I think
extended break a little bit but I think
uh no with with Doug we're finishing
usually close to four I think the games
were taking a little bit longer but as
the tournament is approaching the end I
think some of the players maybe are
getting a little bit tired and
um
maybe more mistakes are happening but
don't forget to continue watching us
here on Twitch and YouTube we'll be back
live tomorrow at 11 30
a.m but Julian hopefully you'll be
joining me again tomorrow morning for
the final round of the super Swiss for
sure Tune In Tune in next time to see us
do commentary on the St Louis super
Swiss thank you everyone and don't
forget about the American Cup starting
on Friday bye for now
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chess capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined 300 thousand dollars in prizes
we will cover all the action live from
the World Chess Hall of Fame from March
17th through March 26th tune in for the
best game in chess streaming live for
more information visit uschesschamps.com
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited